in the wake of a violent riot that ended
in actually taking over the u.s
capitol leaving at least five dead
including one capital police officer
cries for removing the president as
expediently as possible are coming from
both sides of the aisle
but this isn't an episode of the west
wing this is
actually real life can the 25th
amendment actually be invoked to remove
president trump from
office is that a legal possibility
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a constitutional scholar because
we are through the looking glass people
we are in uncharted territory
because people are furious with
president trump not just for
potentially inciting the violent mob
that eventually took over the capital
but also with his lack of a response
after the fact his
inability to calm the crowd and
basically seeming like he was
awol people are suggesting that the
president is now
incapable of discharging his duties so
what do we do in that situation
well a lot of people have pointed to the
25th amendment
which was created to have a backup plan
in case the president was
incapacitated or otherwise incapable of
performing their duties
now the us constitution's original plan
for what happens in the event of a
presidential disability or inability to
work
was simply for the vice president to
take over but that was
pretty vague it seems simple enough but
article 2 section 1 clause 6 of the
constitution
doesn't exactly explain how to decide
when a president is considered disabled
or
unable to perform the duties of the
office so
in 1967 congress passed the 25th
amendment which was intended to provide
clarity in these really dire situations
and if you've ever seen the west wing
you've probably seen a couple of these
25th amendment scenarios play out
but this is real life and the real 25th
amendment
has several sections the first is
section 3 which is
a part of the 25th amendment that has
actually been invoked several times
section 3 of the 25th amendment provides
that the president has the authority to
declare him or herself
unable to discharge the powers of the
office
if the president makes this declaration
it officially transfers authority of the
office to the vice president who
exercises it as acting president until
the actual president
reclaims their authority by declaring
that the disability has ended
so why in the world would a president
ever
willingly give up power to the vice
president well
it's generally in times of medical
emergencies or
sometimes even routine medical
procedures so for example this could
apply if the president was having
surgery and
knew that he or she was going to go
under the knife and was going to be
incapacitated for that time
the key aspect of section 3 is that the
president has discretion over when it
applies and
when it ends and this has happened
before ronald reagan sent a letter
suggesting that he was invoking section
3 of the 25th amendment when he
underwent surgery for a polyp
george h.w bush was acting president for
about eight hours while
president reagan was in surgery and
after that president reagan took back
his power as the actual president
similarly when george w bush was
president he formally invoked section 3
of the 25th amendment twice
when he was anesthetized for routine
medical procedures each time
the vice president dick cheney took over
on both occasions and then
when the president felt better was
declared fit for office and
retook their power as the president of
the united states and
believe it or not took the power away
from vice president dick cheney
but while this is an interesting history
lesson this is obviously
not the scenario that people are talking
about in january 2021.
what people are talking about in the
context of basically forcibly removing
the president from power
refers to section 4 of the 25th
amendment
and section 4 of the 25th amendment is
far more complicated
and contested than section 3. following
the siege of the capital there have been
lots of calls for invoking the 25th
amendment and removing president trump
from power and
installing vice president pence as the
acting president
nancy pelosi the speaker of the house
has called for it chuck schumer the
minority senate leader though soon to be
majority leader
former chief of staff john kelly has
called for president trump's removal via
the 25th amendment
and even mick mulvaney who just resigned
his post
and was the former director of omb
former director of the cfpb
and the former white house chief of
staff has suggested that the 25th
amendment should be in play
and all of them are referring to section
4 of the 25th amendment
so there is a process for removing a
president
from power who is either unwilling or
unable to
uh transfer power themselves it's
actually never happened the
section 4 of the 25th amendment has
never been invoked
and obviously it's highly political now
what most people think about when they
think of the 25th amendment
is a president who is suddenly taken ill
maybe
was in a car crash and is put on a
ventilator or
has to go into emergency surgery for i
don't know a heart condition or
any of the million things that could
actually befall
an actual human president and if they
are in an emergency if they're uh under
surgery under general anesthetic or
in a coma then the 25th amendment could
apply because the president wouldn't
have the ability to make the
determination
for themselves that they have to
transfer power
at the same time the authors of the
amendment also wanted to cover scenarios
where the president thinks that he or
she is totally fine
but that the vice president and a
majority of the cabinet think that the
president is not actually fine
remember that america is a country that
was created in part because the
colonists didn't want to be ruled by
king george iii who was said to be
suffering from madness so if a president
is unwilling to declare him or herself
incapacitated
then the cabinet and the vice president
may act in these circumstances the
section authorizes the vice president
and a majority of either the cabinet
or any other body established by law
acting jointly to declare the president
to be disabled
in for all intents and purposes we're
talking about the vice president and
the members of the president's cabinet
of which there are 15 members
specifically section 4 of the 25th
amendment provides that quote
whenever the vice president and a
majority of either the principal
officers of the executive departments
or of such other bodies congress may by
law provide transmit to the president
temporary of the senate and the speaker
of the house of representatives their
written declaration
the president is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of his office
the vice president shall immediately
assume the powers and duties of the
office as acting president
now the key phrase here is the president
is unable to discharge the powers and
duties of
the office at the moment president trump
is not in a coma
he's not incapacitated as most people
would generally define that word
and this might be a little bit
controversial but i think most people
would agree he's not suffering from
something like
dementia so it could be an open question
as to whether the president's
indecision or inability to attempt to
prevent
the mob that took over the capital or to
effectively run the country in the wake
of this
this horrible tragedy whether that
qualifies as the sort of
inability to discharge the powers and
duties of the office that is
contemplated by the 25th amendment
now practically speaking the 25th
amendment requires a majority of the
cabinet officers
agree with the vice president the
president is unable to fulfill their
duties
there are 15 cabinet positions as we've
talked about so the vice president would
need
a concurrence of at least eight of the
15 cabinet members to activate a
declaration of presidential disability
now let's put aside for the moment the
fact that the trump cabinet is currently
full of acting cabinet members and
has lost a lot of the senate confirmed
cabinet members that
i think the 25th amendment originally
contemplates but we'll get back to that
but again talking about the practicality
of this for the moment
once a majority of the cabinet and the
vice president notify the president pro
tem and the speaker
the vice president immediately assumes
the powers and duties of
the office of acting president but the
drafters of the 25th amendment were well
aware that this opened up the
possibility that the president was being
removed solely for political reasons
like the country was just tired of him
or the vice president was plotting a
coup
so the amendment gives the president a
way to get back in and reclaim
their power from the vice president the
way that works is this and it's a little
bit complicated
once the vice president invokes the
presidential disability
the vice president becomes acting
president but
the president then the original
president at the time of their choice
can transmit a written message to the
president pro tem
and the speaker that no disability
exists and that the president should
then
resume power of the presidency but the
thing is the president doesn't get that
power back immediately
once the president has made a
declaration that they are objecting to
the decision of the vice president in
the cabinet the vice president and the
cabinet then have four days to respond
so this sets up a potential showdown
because the vice president and the
majority of the cabinet
have four days to contest this finding
this objection by the president
if they think the president is still
incapable of
serving of discharging the duties so if
in those four days the vice president
and the cabinet still believe the
president is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of the office
then the decision goes to congress and
at that point
if two-thirds of both houses of congress
believe that the president
is unable to discharge the duties of
office then the vice president continues
as acting president
until that disability is resolved or
until the end of the term
but if the two-thirds margin is not
obtained or if congress is in session at
the time but
doesn't vote on the question within 21
days of receiving the declaration then
the president has to resume the powers
and duties of the office
similarly if congress is not in session
at the time and assembles but doesn't
vote within 21 days then the president
resumes the powers and duties of the
office like i said
this is complicated but really
practically speaking the way it works is
this
the vice president declares the
president is disabled so
at that point if the majority of the
cabinet agrees
the vice president immediately becomes
acting president
at that point the president can object
and let's say that the president objects
immediately at the same time that the
vice president
takes power then the vice president and
cabinet have four days to decide
if they agree and if the vice president
and cabinet still believe that the
president is disabled then
the decision goes over to congress who
have to act within
a maximum of 21 days although they can
obviously
act sooner now as i said section 4 has
never been activated since the amendment
was ratified in 1967
but there were two events during
reagan's presidency where
arguably it should have been invoked on
march 30th 1981 president reagan was
shot and seriously wounded while leaving
a speaking engagement in washington it
was actually
just down the street from where i live
president reagan had emergency surgery
and he was under anesthesia
his aides debated whether or not to
invoke section 4 of the 25th amendment
they were all notified that a full
recovery was expected
and decided that no further action was
needed
but when president reagan was shot al
haig the secretary of state
made a huge mistake and told the press
that he was in control while the
president was
in surgery as of now i am in control
here
in the white house pending return of the
vice president and in close touch with
him
if something came up i would check with
him of course this was considered
a huge mistake in faux pas and sort of
demonstrated
constitutional ignorance by a
high-ranking official because
the secretary of state is not the person
who takes over when the president
is incapacitated and while many people
remember
al haig's comment and the constitutional
crisis that it almost created
fewer people are aware that section 4 of
the 25th amendment was also in play
during the waning days of
reagan's presidency because in the last
days of the presidency his
mental status was also questioned by
staff while he was in office
in 1987 former senator howard baker
president reagan's newly appointed chief
of staff
reportedly received a memorandum from an
aide that claimed that the president was
inattentive and inept the memorandum
went on to urge baker to consider the
possibility
that section 4 of the 25th amendment
might be applied
baker concluded that the president was
attentive and alert and on march
2nd after a meeting he dismissed this
report
of course we all know how this ended
because five years after president
reagan left the presidency
he was diagnosed with alzheimer's
disease and rarely
made public appearances after that but
fast forward 35 years to today
and as much as we know about the 25th
amendment there's actually a lot that we
don't know as well
we don't know if the key phrase unable
to discharge the powers and duties of
his office applies
in this particular situation with
president trump if that was disputed we
don't know what the supreme court would
say it's entirely possible that
if someone disputed this application the
25th amendment
assuming that they even had standing i
suppose it would be
a deposed president trump who would be
making the claim
if they had standing it's entirely
possible the supreme court would call
this a political question and refuse to
adjudicate it
and the really big known unknown is the
fact that
president trump's cabinet is full of
acting secretaries because he basically
just
stopped sending cabinet members to be
confirmed by the senate
at the moment we have acting cabinet
members in charge of the department of
justice the department of defense and of
homeland security
as well as the department of
transportation elaine chao
mitch mcconnell's wife just resigned
from the being the head of the
department of
transportation but as law professor
brian cult who is
basically the foremost expert in the
25th amendment explains
a lot of people assume that acting
secretaries can't vote on the 25th
amendment
but at most it's unclear there's a
potential scholarly consensus that
the acting secretaries can vote based
mainly
on a 1965 house committee report but
again
it's unclear and at most if the acting
cabinet members cannot vote then that
would lower the number of
cabinet officials that would need to be
in the majority to
invoke the 25th amendment but we also
don't know if this is a complete and
total pipe dream
people on the left have been calling for
invoking the 25th amendment
against president trump basically as
long as the president has been
in the office and reports say that vice
president pence
has no interest in invoking the 25th
amendment despite the fact that
there are calls for him to invoke it
from across the aisle
what we do know is that if the 25th
amendment
was invoked president trump would no
longer be president
immediately and he wouldn't be president
for at least four days then
an additional potential up to 21 days
would
also uh prevent him from retaking the
office even if congress
refused to do anything and at the time
of this recording there's
only two weeks left in the president's
term
and invoking the 25th amendment could
keep him out of office
until the end of his term and
additionally the 25th amendment is not
mutually exclusive to
impeachment and removal as others have
called for as well
you can do both and on the other hand
there might be a good reason to invoke
the 25th amendment because
it works immediately in part because it
might be necessary to prevent a massive
wave of pardons right now bloomberg
reports that president trump is
considering a whole raft of people
including himself
mark meadows stephen miller john mcentee
dan scavino ivanka trump jared kushner
rudy giuliani kimberly guilfoyle
albert pirro lil wayne and kodak black
i'm gonna go out on a limb in opine that
that would be a bad thing
but perhaps we're being too precious
with the office of the presidency
the president is not a king ordained by
god
lots of democracies have votes of no
confidence that allow the legislatures
to
kick out the top executive effectively
whenever they want and
there's lots of good reasons why you
might want to do that
and four years for a president to serve
their term
is a long time it's a long
long time but i leave that to you do you
agree with my analysis
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
which talk about the crazy legal issues
of the day because there are
a lot of them so click on this playlist
and i'll see you
in court